the protesters here are fighting back
attempting to defend themselves with
fireworks and Molotov cocktails
the police have brought in armored
vehicles they're using them to try to
break through the barricades the
protesters are using them as targets
this time successfully forcing the
police to retreat under fire stumbling
from the flames a number clearly injured
on the ground
[Music]
the Podesta's have homemade shields and
numbers the police have water cannon and
stun grenades the protesters are helping
to carry their wounded away the remains
of what were their tents burning in
Independence Square fueling a sense of
desperation and injustice there will be
a new round of guerrilla war in the
regions in the villages in the districts
we will be destroying sets an on fire
and demanding justice because we have
nothing to lose now and nowhere to go
the leaders of the opposition met the
president last night they left with no
deal saying the talks had bought nothing
good just gone from the installation our
main goal and I told the president right
now he has stopped to cleaning am I done
because every minute died people and
just one way to stop that and to
continue negotiation tomorrow the
president says the opposition are
attempting to seize power he appealed to
the citizens of Ukraine to stand with
him the opposition leaders have ignored
the basic foundation of democracy power
is gained not on streets or maidens but
in electoral districts the line has been
crossed when they called people to arms
this is a grave breaking of the law the
law breakers must stand trial before the
court that will determine their level of
guilt there are injuries here on both
sides
this is escalating rapidly known and
utterly
the protest headquarters were set on
fire last night people forced to claim
during the site of the building to
escape but even as the fires burn in
Independence Square they're singing the
national anthem
[Music]
they're standing together here now
determined to defend this ground and
what it means